the white house has just released its
christmas photo
so the biden white house christmas photo
showed a fireplace mantle hung with
stockings for six of joe biden's
grandchildren
it's very nice sort of elegant design in
the grand room six stockings wait a
second
joe biden
has seven grandchildren
but there's only six stockings there and
they've got all their little names on
there so it's clearly for the
grandchildren now you might say this is
just because joe biden's forgetful he is
very forgetful but i don't know jill
biden's not that forgetful and the white
house staff is certainly not forgetful
oh right one of those grandchildren
is illegitimate it was the grandchild
that hunter biden had
with
london roberts who was a stripper
and hunter biden refused to acknowledge
the baby and then a court forced him to
take a paternity test and then it turned
out he was the father meaning joe biden
is the grandfather and joe biden refuses
to acknowledge his own grandkid
according to london roberts's attorney
neither hunter biden nor joe biden the
warm wonderful happy good old uncle joe
president has ever seen the
three-year-old child
i really do not mean this as a cheap
political attack i don't mean this to go
after family or anything like that
not very much shocks me in politics
but
i am genuinely impressed by the cruelty
of the president of the united states
joe biden
in refusing to acknowledge one of his
own grandchildren
yeah hunter biden's a complete
degenerate i don't expect anything of
him he's a crooked
degenerate
but what about joe biden
i'm not gonna i don't want to take any
cheap political attacks here at joe i
just think joe says he's a nice guy he's
a normal guy he's a devout catholic
right and he is cruelly refusing to
acknowledge one of his own grandchildren
the president of the united states
shouldn't that be a scandal
what is this kid going to think the
kid's three years old now probably
doesn't understand too much what is this
kid going to think
i think it's a she i don't know let's
just say it's a she
i'll look at i don't know very much
about about the kid and navy's sort of
ambiguous name as so many are these days
but what is this child going to think
when she grows up
and is 9 or 10 years old says uh why
won't my daddy acknowledge me why won't
my grandpa the president of the united
states acknowledge me i'm not good
enough
i'm i'm a mistake i'm an accident i'm a
shame i'm a problem i'm a humiliation
that's a horrible thing to do to a child
that's all that is a genuinely horrible
thing that joe biden is doing right now
and i try to resist all the easy
political attacks on hunter biden even
though there are plenty of legitimate
attacks because he was compromising
national security he was selling
america's
influence around the world to the
highest bidder i mean there were a lot
of serious problems with hunter i try to
lay off the hunter
stuff but what joe it's not even
hunter's
problem so i don't have any expectations
of him what joe biden is doing here is
disgusting it's despicable it's shameful
it's extremely cruel and it should be a
national scandal and more people should
talk about it i'm glad you liked that
clip now i need you to ring the bell
i need it
i need it i don't ask for very much do i
no i don't
just gotta ring that bell you get the
notifications if you don't get the
notifications because of our friends at
big tech then maybe head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe
maybe leave a five star review
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you